good morning John so probably in part
because I take a medicine to control an
autoimmune disease I got a special kind
of covid that goes away and then it
comes back again it's a bit of a
struggle that has me looking for for the
bright side of things and I did finally
lose my sense of smell slash taste and
and you don't actually lose your your
taste you got your sour Bitter Sweet
salty Umami you keep those but you lose
all of the complexity of the nose you
get five tastes but yet like tens of
thousands of smell it's amazing and for
whatever reason it stopped working in me
and this has made me curious because I
like most foods but there are some foods
that I literally just taste like poison
to me and I wonder if without the smell
component of taste which is a big part
of taste will I still dislike that
things that I dislike tend to be
vinegary and vinegar is very sour so my
guess is that if I eat something
vinegary I'm gonna still hate it but you
never know
ah I have never enjoyed a pickle so
let's see what happens
that's very bad there's a lot of
bitterness I'm sitting here though and
now I kind of want more of it oh no I
also like all rational people don't
understand why people have black
licorice so let's crack that open as
well it sounds really delicious right on
the label so that's a big hunk okay oh
absolutely fantastic I hate black
licorice this is great they're just
sweet of course they're sweet and then
there's like a nice mix of a bitter sour
that's doing a great job of
complementing the sweetness wow that's
great oh my gosh it's really delicious
if my sense of smell never comes back I
will take everybody's black licorice
everything that's good all right I'm
also not a fan of blue cheese so in
order to make sure I'm doing the Lord's
work here let's get a big like way more
than I would ever eat this even of a
normal cheese oh that's good shockingly
sweet very salty wow that's good whoa
whoa blue cheese is great when you can't
smell I would never have thought that it
would be sweet I might eat all of that
I'm gonna get some crackers I guess is
that I'm still not gonna like anchovies
just how I didn't like pickles because
they're basically just pickles but fish
instead of cucumbers but you never know
three two one
oh God ah
there's no water in here oh my God I'm a
spit machine right now oh uh that's
clearly an ingredient it's not a thing
you eat on its own in that package of
anchovies there's 74 of your daily salt
so that's not that's not a good food all
right now for the Moment of Truth uh
there's a lot left in my bag here but
all of it is olives we're gonna start
off with black olives I don't know which
olives are more Olive who knows maybe
they're good without smell this is an
olive
well it's not vinegary at all it's just
salty that's good
that's what an olive tasted like I would
eat all this salty it's got a little
little bit of something like a like a
richness maybe it's just fatty like a
fatty flavor that's quite nice and then
the salt is a little much that's a good
that was a good experience I figured I
was gonna hate that honestly and to
finish this off I believe designed
specifically for people who do not have
a sense of taste it's blue cheese
stuffed green olives I'm gonna make a
prediction I'm gonna say these are gonna
be too salty why do I keep smelling
things anyway
ah very salty
but the cheese brings a lot of like
sweetness and sourness to it and that's
great that's great
that's good it's a good texture the
cheese is a really nice texture to it
there is something there now I feel like
I'm getting in my in my smell Zone
there's not Olive flavor it's like a
rich nutty feeling that's delish if you
like the flavor of Olives olives would
be great but unfortunately for me when I
can actually taste them they taste like
poison John thanks for hanging out as I
search for some bright side and it is
this I got to eat olives without hating
them and black licorice too that was my
favorite part because honestly not a lot
of bright sides to this almost as if
covid really sucks obviously feeling a
little bit better now but main thing
from my experience rest lay down no
pressure convalesce and that's what I've
mostly been doing John I'll see you on
Tuesday